Yeah. I've seen enough. Send it. Shut them down.
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory, the
show that's been lost in The Backrooms for over
a year now. Please send help. At this point,
I'm sure we all know what The Backrooms is,
right? This Creepypasta turned analog horror
series created by indie filmmaker Kane Pixels
absolutely took YouTube by storm last year with
its haunting aesthetics, its mysterious story,
and its deep lore just begging to be uncovered.
And that has actually become a big part of the
franchise, something that Kane talked about in a
recent interview with my friend Anthony Padilla.
Oh, is that so? Then why did
your characters follow my advice
as I pointed out in a recent YouTube
short? I'm not just coping here, am I?
Well, poop. But then again, I can't blame him.
What Kane's been doing with the series so far
has worked really well, well enough that it's
caught the attention of people well beyond our
little corner of Internet analog horror.
Yeah, in case you didn't hear this one,
Kane has actually teamed up with movie
studio A24 to make a feature length big
budget adaptation of his Backroom series, with
Kane himself directing. That right there, that
is a big deal. A24 are the people behind instant
classics like Everything Everywhere All at Once,
Ex Machina, The Witch, Midsommar, Hereditary.
My first thought after hearing this news. Wow,
congratulations to Kane. I am so excited
to see how this thing turns out. My
second thought after hearing the news,
though, are they allowed to do this? See,
while Kane’s series is really original in
and of itself. It's based on a viral meme.
Kane didn't come up with the original idea of The
Backrooms, and he's openly admitted to that fact.
So it got me to thinking, who actually
owns the copyright to The Backrooms? See,
this is an interesting question because we don't
actually know who came up with The Backrooms. We
know when and where it was invented, but
not who made it. The idea originated in a
thread on 4chan's paranormal themed /x/ image
board on May 12th, 2019, asking users to post
images that felt off in some way or another.
One reply posted this picture of a large room
with yellow wallpaper, which first appeared in
another thread back in 2018. Someone else replied
to this image, writing the caption that would then
go on to set the tone for the entire idea of The
Backrooms from that point forward: “The stink of
old moist carpet, the madness of mono-yellow, the
endless background noise of fluorescent lights.”
But here's the thing. By default, all the 4chan’s
posters are anonymous, so we have no idea
who first posted the image and who first
wrote the caption. So the whole idea kind of
just transcended into Internet Creepypasta
folklore where Kane eventually found it and
then used it as an inspiration for his own
series. Now all of that in and of itself is
really cool, and it's made for an incredible
community driven writing project as hundreds of
people contribute to the lore of The Backrooms.
But the introduction of a film into the mix by
an actual Oscar winning movie studio like A24,
that right there, that changes things. Because
The Backrooms is no longer the territory of the
Internet Wild West. It's now in a more traditional
setting. And as Kane himself has pointed out,
all of this unofficial, unlicensed
content can start to become a problem.
He's definitely not wrong. And this problem
becomes a lot more tricky when you realize the
Kane’s series could qualify as the same sort of
unofficial, unlicensed content. So today I want
to dive into this issue and see if we can work
out what's what. If those original posts were,
in fact, anonymous, who actually owns The
Backrooms? Does anyone in The Backrooms?
and its Kane’s series and this big budget
movie all at risk of copyright infringement?
Is all of this the end of The Backrooms as we
know it? Put on your hazmat suits, loyal theorist,
because we're headed to the most terrifying
and endless labyrinth of them all: Copyright
law. Before we get started, at this point, I feel
like it goes without saying. But just to be clear,
I am not a lawyer. This is not legal advice.
These are just the findings that I was able
to dig up during my research. Also, we're only
going to be talking about copyright law as it
pertains to the U.S., not because other countries
and their laws are unimportant. But more because
the person Kane and the company A24 that we're
talking about here are in the U.S.. Cool? Cool.
So I think the first question we need to answer
here is, can an anonymous work be copyrighted? I
mean, it might be kind of hard to just stroll
down to the U.S. Copyright Office wearing a
disguise and then filling out some forms
without listing names, right? No, actually,
you can absolutely file for copyright protection
without filling in any sort of author's name.
But even so, you wouldn't need to in the
first place. You don't actually need to
formally register a creative work with the
government to get that copyright protection.
You actually get that protection the
moment that your work is created,
whether or not you're known to be the creator
of the work. The highest profile example of
this in recent years has got to be the anonymous
graffiti artist Banksy, who defended their artwork
from being used by a greeting card company by
using the copyright protection on set artwork.
Now, to be fair, this case happened over in
Europe, but this sort of anonymous copyright
protection works exactly the same way
in the U.S. We actually go into a lot
of detail about copyrights, trademarks and how
films like Winnie the Pooh: Blood and Honey are
Disney's worst nightmare in another video. But
the long and short of it: under the Copyright
Term Extension Act for an anonymous work.
Anything created in the U.S. has copyright
protection for 95 years after its first published,
or for 120 years after its first creation,
whichever comes first. All of this together,
then, should mean bad news for Kane and The
Backrooms movie right? Since the original 4chan
post was published in 2019, the copyright for
it shouldn't expire until 2114. So if that's
the case, Kane might want to take down his
videos for the next couple of decades, right?
Well, maybe not. We've established that anonymous
works are protected by copyright, but our next
question here is whether or not this sort of
4chan post can even be copyrightable in the first
place. Short answer. Yes. Long answer. Eehhhh It's
complicated. Copyright protects original works
fixed in any tangible medium of expression.
Basically, if you make something original
and creative, you own the copyright for it:
book, movie, music, architecture, YouTube
video or my personal favorite pantomime.
Now the bar for originality and creativity are
pretty darn low in the eyes of the law. So the
original picture from The Backrooms absolutely
qualifies. Whoever took that picture of the room
and posted it 4chan created the image. So
check there for originality. And they were
exercising some level of creativity in the
choice of the subject, how it was framed,
the choice to do it at Dutch Angle, etc..
Same thing for the separate person who wrote
the caption. Obviously it's original insofar as
they came up with the ideas and they wrote them.
And there's no denying that it's brimming with
creativity, setting a bleak scene and creating
a captivating horror scenario. It also passes
the bar and gets copyright protection. However,
even if the picture and the text are separately
protected by copyright law, it's important to
remember the scope of said protection.
First of all, even if it's found that
something is directly violating the copyright
of the post, it's going to be difficult for the
original authors to come forward with a case. The
original 4chan posts have long since been deleted,
along with any potentially identifying information
like IP addresses. And these authors are going
to have a difficult time proving that they
were the ones who originally made the post.
Secondly, even if they could prove their
ownership, it's probably not even worth the legal
hassle. Though you don't lose copyright protection
on your work if you don't enforce that protection,
how vigorously you protect your work is
factored into a court's judgment on the
matter. For example, if you took a photograph
and wrote a caption for it that was then widely
circulated across image boards, YouTube,
Twitter, and dedicated fan wikis for years.
And you never took any action until real money
came along? Yeah, the judge is going to take
that into consideration. Anything you might win
in damages might not even be enough to cover the
legal fees. Thirdly, sure you can copyright
individual works, but you can't copyright
ideas. Just because someone takes a picture of
a creepy room with fluorescent lights and yellow
wallpaper doesn't mean that they're the only one
with copyright to that aesthetic and that no one
can ever take another picture of a creepy room
with fluorescent lights and yellow wallpaper.
The copyright protection of this original
Backrooms photograph is limited to this
single photograph. So, yeah, if Kane wants to use
this exact specific image in his series or movie,
sure, that might be a problem. But he clearly
hasn't done that. He's created entirely new
imagery for his videos. And as for the text,
sure these two sentences and the way that they
express their ideas are protected by copyright.
But the ideas themselves, they're not protected.
Even something specific, like the word Backrooms,
which Kane took from the post to use as the name
of the series wouldn't be protected here. Why?
Well you can't copyright names, titles, words or
short phrases. That kind of stuff falls under the
domain of trademarks. Another thing that we cover
in more detail over in that Winnie the Pooh video.
Additionally, the word and idea of a Backroom;
you know, a room in the back of a business or
office or whatever, has existed long before that
4chan post. So it's not exactly something you can
just decide is yours because you took a picture
or thought of a spooky story. Obviously, Kane
lifted the general vibe of The Backrooms from the
original image and caption: the yellow wallpaper,
fluorescent light, liminal spaces, all that jazz.
He also took the general idea of The Backrooms
being huge and full of weird stuff. And again,
just to clear up any ambiguity here, Kane admits
that he was very much inspired by the post.
Other than that though? not a whole
lot here sticks. Plenty of ideas are
reminiscent of content from the original
Backrooms post or the Backrooms wiki;
People in Kane's series fall into The Backrooms in
a way that seems visually similar to noclipping.
But Kane has never once used the word no
clipping to describe that process in his
canon. Sometimes strange noises that sound
like a party can be heard in Kane's videos,
which could be a reference to the
party goers from the wiki’s canon.
But again, Kane has never brought the actual party
goers or their lore into his world. Even ideas
like the size of The Backrooms in Kane’s series
aren't 1 to 1 with the original post. Sure, Kane's
Backrooms are big, but it's never one specifically
mentioned to be 600 million square miles like the
original post described it. Pretty much the only
things that Kane took from that original post are
the yellow vibe, the idea of falling into and
getting lost and the words “The Backrooms”.
Most everything else in these videos are entirely
original creations of Kane's, the organization
Async and their goals, project KV31 and the
portal into The Backrooms, the Bacteria Monster.
Sorry, the Lifeform Fellow… Sure. Well, anyway,
that was still Kane’s. The long and short of
it is that he's more than in the clear to make a
film about the original story that he's crafted.
But see, Kane's not the person I'm worried about
in this episode. After all of this research into
copyright law, the quirks of anonymity
and who owns what in this circumstance,
he's going to be fine. He's well within his legal
rights to partner with A24 and make this movie,
and I'm excited to see what comes of
it. No, I'm more worried about us.
You, me, and all those small creators out
there. What concerns me now is what that,
this movie, is going to mean for the sorts of
crowdsourced online horror stories that The
Backrooms represent. I fear that this could spell
disaster for these sorts of stories. Why? Well,
because even if Kane and A24 are in the
clear to make their Backrooms movie,
they're likely going to want to protect
that film to the letter of the law.
Now, don't misunderstand me. I don't think that
Kane is going to be going after people for making
their own original Backrooms content. I don't
think he wants to do that. He has been nothing
but a kind and thoughtful guy every time that
we've interacted. And even in that interview
with Anthony, he explained his thoughts on
the whole communal ownership of ideas thing.
That right there, that is a great way to
look at projects like The Backrooms. No,
the problem here isn't going to be coming from
Kane, it's going to be coming from the studios.
Making the jump from online video to major motion
picture involves a lot of money. A LOT of money.
In budget, sure, but also in potential
returns from movie ticket sales and merch.
If you go and look up the highest grossing media
franchises of all time, you'll see that the lion's
share of their revenue actually comes from the
merch. It's true for Pokemon, Star Wars, Mickey
Mouse, Winnie the Pooh, Minecraft. And if this
Backrooms movie is a hit I could absolutely
see this sort of thing happening here too.
Just imagine: Hazmat guy action figures, Lifeform
Fellow plushies. Kane may or may not be interested
in this part of the show business, but the
Hollywood producers he's working with definitely
are. And that means that they're going to want to
protect their IP vigorously so they're the ones
making that money. I mean, this exact scenario has
happened before. You'll remember Slender Man? He's
a pillar of online Creepypasta folklore. And just
like The Backrooms, everyone felt like they owned
a part of Slenderman. And at the beginning, things
definitely operated that way. That's why you saw
so many free, low budget indie projects centered
on The Slender Man: Slender the eight pages,
Marble Hornets. But once the idea of Slenderman
became a phenomenon and caught the attention of
larger media companies, when real money
started to get involved, things changed.
Eric Knutson, the original creator of Slender Man,
had to step up to stop shady, low quality content
from destroying his idea. He became more involved
in for profit projects like Slender The Arrival,
and eventually he sold the rights to the
character entirely to Mythology Entertainment,
who went on to block independent crowdfunded
movies from release and then made their own
big budget film with Sony Pictures.
Again, I cannot stress enough how much
I don't think Kane wants this to happen,
but when you're dealing with Hollywood,
this sort of stuff becomes inevitable. What
then, do we do here, loyal theorists? If The
Backrooms film is successful, I don't want there
to be some sort of gold rush of all these major
movie studios trying to take their claim on any
and every viral creepypasta in Internet folklore.
Does anyone really want or need the EA funded
Jeff the Killer game? a Universal Studios Ben
Drowned movie? A Lavender Town Netflix
miniseries? I don't think so. Thankfully,
there are ways to protect yourself, your work
and your favorite content creators using the
exact same copyright laws that got us started down
this road in the first place. First and foremost,
if you create something and post it online,
make sure you sign it, make sure that it's
attributed to you either with your real name
or an online alias that you can prove is yours.
That way, people know that this was your
work from the second that you uploaded it.
It is unambiguously yours and your creative
rights are protected by copyright. I mean,
that's why they're there, after all, might
as well put them to use. And on top of this,
make sure that you're posting to platforms
that respect those rights and don't have
anything shady hidden in their end user license
agreements that somehow transfer any ownership of
content posted there to their website.
You'd actually be surprised how many
fairly large websites have clauses like
this, and that is really not cool. Next,
if you can create your own characters and use your
own ideas, obviously those will always belong to
you and no one's going to be able to use that
content without your approval. That being said,
it can be difficult. So third, if you do want
to build off of something that already exists,
make sure that what you're building off of is
either in the public domain or it's basic enough
that what you contribute will clearly be yours.
What am I talking about? Well, some of it's
obvious you want to write stories about
ancient mythology, folklore, fairy tales,
stuff like Thor or the Baba Yaga or The Little
Mermaid, you are almost certainly in the clear
as long as what you write isn't taken from
other modern interpretations of those same
ideas. Other things that you should be good to
use are urban legends and cryptids, stuff like:
Bigfoot, Mothman, Bloody Mary.
No single person owns those ideas,
and you could just make some incredibly
unique stories using them as jumping off
points. This also applies if you want to create
something using basic ideas to build off of,
like with The Backrooms. Take the same idea that
Kane used as the basis for a series and then build
your own ideas on top of it, away from Kane’s.
You don't need to use Async or project KV31 or
the Lifeform Fellow to tell a compelling story
about The Backrooms. All you gotta do is take
an idea that you like and change it enough that
it becomes your own thing. Great example of this:
The Enderman from Minecraft. They were originally
spoofs of Slenderman. I mean, the name alone makes
it pretty darn obvious. But over the years, the
Enderman have had their own quirks and lore added,
they've become completely unique from their
slender origins. You can do the exact same thing;
using ideas that you like and then changing
them enough to make them yours and yours alone.
So all of that protects you and your work.
But what if we want to protect the collective
works? Stuff like the incredible community driven
lore that's popped up around The Backrooms? Well,
we have the perfect template to look to with
the SCP wiki. If you somehow don't know, the SCP
Foundation is a collaborative writing project
where users submit articles about fictional
objects, locations and characters, all inspired
by elements of horror, sci-fi and urban fantasy.
A lot of this content is similar in tone to The
Backrooms. Once an article is approved to go up
on the website, though, anyone is free to take the
ideas from that article and add it to their own
work, both on and off the SCP website. Everything
published on the SCP wiki is done through the
Creative Commons attribution-sharealike
3.0 license or CC-BY-SA for short.
That means that anyone is free to make content
based on SCPs. They can even make money. But
they have to credit the original authors and
then also publish their work under that same
sharealike license. That means that yes,
anyone from an indie game dev to a major
movie studio can profit from the SCP wiki and
their articles, but the ideas that they add
to the SCP must also be free for anyone
else to use, publish and profit from.
Though this might not work for everything,
this is an awesome system for these sorts of
collaborative projects. And maybe the single
most important thing to keep in mind about
all of this: support the independent writers
and artists that you love so they can keep
creating. Read the work of these creators, share
them with your friends, help spread the word.
One of my particular favorites that I haven't
seen reach the same level of success is The
Backrooms or SCP yet are the short stories by
the Reddit user SearchAndRescueWoods. They have
a series about these mysterious staircases
just appearing out in the woods and their
connections to missing persons. It is great.
Remember, the next Backrooms, Slenderman and
SCP Foundation is out there somewhere just
waiting to be discovered. So please share
some of your favorites down in the comments.
And check out what everyone else is posting
down there. I know I'll be excited to see
what you guys are saying down there because
who knows? Maybe one day it'll appear here
in a theory. Until that day comes though,
remember! It's all just a theory. A FILM THEORY!
Aaaaaand I know that I mentioned this video a
couple of times in this episode, but if you want
to learn more about copyright and trademark and
how it is shaping the creative landscape as we
know it, that Winnie the Pooh horror movie episode
is on the left. It is a very cool discussion
about something that is very scary to Disney
right now. Or if you're tired of legal stuff and
just want to catch up on the latest Backrooms
lore. Our latest lore video is over on the right.
As always, my friends, I'll see you next week.